there is a not so funny lie down in
Atlanta this not so funny lie involves
an officer-involved killing it involves
the burning of that Wendy is this we
went through this whole video point by
point a couple days ago the Atlanta PD
officer that was involved in that
officer involving has now been charged
with felony murder and other charges
according to the Fulton County District
Attorney Paul Howard we went through the
video we pointed out that it's a very
sad video why is it a sad video why is
it a disturbing video because it's sad
and disturbing when anyone gets shot
regardless of the circumstances but we
went through point by point and showed
there is no way to argue this was not
justified the guy the the perp in this
case the cops were talking to him they
tried to de-escalate the situation that
tried to calmly arrest him he busted out
wrestled the cops the cops still didn't
use a lot of force he threw the cops off
of him cops still didn't use a lot of
force he grabbed their taser gun cops
still didn't use a lot of force he ran
away cops still didn't use a lot of
force then he turns around points the
taser gun at them and fires finally the
cops discharged their weapons very said
it shouldn't turned out that way but
obviously a justified use of force you
can't have law enforcement without some
use of force and now because of mob rule
in this country and more than that
because we've given in to a bunch of
dishonest premises this guy's life might
be ruined the other officer on the scene
faces three charges including aggravated
assault
the cop now who is being brought up on
murder charges as Garrett Rolf the other
cop Devon Brosnan has been put on
administrative duty and the rolfe has
been fired already even if he weren't
charged with murder fired again is that
justified doesn't seem so to me why is
this happening well in part the
mainstream media are ginning up the
tensions here so here is one I think
representative headline this one came
from was it's ABC Rashard Brooks
remembered for hard work
and dedication to family you'll notice
in this whole incident I have not really
said a thing about Richard Brooks there
are many things to say about Rashard
Brooks but I find it distasteful to
speak ill of the dead and I don't think
there's any reason necessarily to jump
into that if it's not relevant to the
story but now the mainstream media have
made it relevant to the story they've
made us talk about it okay
because they have put an obvious lie
right here
Rashard Brooks remembered for hard work
and dedication to family the only thing
Rashard Brooks is remembered for with
regard to his family is beating his wife
and abusing his children which he was
brought up on charges for and convicted
for not so long ago yeah guys got a long
criminal record I didn't mention the
criminal record when we first went
through this story because I didn't
think it was relevant to whether or not
he would get killed right that's not at
the the cop didn't shoot him because he
has a criminal record nor should he have
he the cop shot him because there was a
threat and Rashard Brooks stole his
weapon and pointed the weapon at him but
now because of the the media lionizing
this man and trying to ruin the cops
life I have to mention it there Rashard
Brooks has a very long rap sheet he did
some very very terrible things like beat
his wife like abuse his child being
completely whitewashed by the media and
so by the way it's not some conspiracy
theory that this happened it's being
acknowledged by other media sources even
in fluff pieces so here's another one
Atlanta shooting victim Rashard Brooks
is Toledo family speaks out this
happened in Atlanta but some of the
family members of Rashard Brooks live in
Toledo so they speak to Rashard Brooks
his father Larry barb I'm and he says
that this according to the article he'd
come in January Rashard of that year to
meet his father Larry Barban whom he'd
never known in his childhood so classic
sad story you've got this other deadbeat
dad Larry Barban who abandons his son
when his son is a little kid and so is
there any particular surprise that there
might be family problems down the line
there no of course not these
kind of issues become generational when
you have family breakdown but then mr.
Barban has the goal to say this we grew
together in that year as if I had never
been out of his life
it just didn't last long because of
racism didn't last long because of
racism I I think it didn't last long
because you didn't take the care to know
your child when he was a child and moved
to a different city that's not racism
fault that this man didn't didn't care
to raise his son it's his fault
Larry Barban so I feel bad for the guy
that he lost his son even though he
didn't know his son but that's not you
can't blame racism for that and then in
the piece this is the this is the
evidence that Rashard Brooks actually
did commit all these horrible crimes
against his own family
mr. Barban believes officers prejudged
his son by the color of his skin and his
criminal record which shows several
charges of theft obstructing an officer
battery on a family member and other
misdemeanors notice the conflation of
these things prejudged based on the
color of his skin we all think that's a
bad thing and his criminal record that's
not that's not prejudging in the scent
that's judging there was a judgement and
you were convicted of crimes some crimes
very bad ones like beating your wife and
abusing your kid not the same thing but
they're trying to blur these issues I
didn't get to know my son because of
racism no you didn't get to know your
son cuz you were a horrible father
that's that's why okay it's still sad
this is this was the same point I made
yesterday when we talked about the
shooting which obviously is what is at
issue here regardless I don't care how
Rashard Brooks ended up dead it's still
sad because a guy ended up shot that's
why the video was disturbing but we
can't conclude from that that simply
because it is said simply because a man
died that it was unjustified and the
person who killed him as a murderer
especially when we have it on tape
especially when we can see that that is
not the case and so as a result of this
this murder charge giving into a mob
rule that has now become it seems
totally lawless Atlanta police officers
are walking
the job
[Music]
you